bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat depuis mardi les sénateurs
examinent le projet de loi notre pour
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république qui répartit les compétences
entre les différentes collectivités
alors ce matin les sénateurs s'attaque
aux compétences des régions en matière
de tourisme
d'un côté le gouvernement voudrait que
les régions chapeaute tout l'action en
matière de tourisme pour plus de
clarifications et moins de saupoudrage
de l'autre et bien certains sénateurs
sont profondément contre la commission
des lois par ailleurs avait supprimé
cette proposition préférant que le
tourisme reste une compétence partagée
le débat s'annonce encore long puisqu'il
reste plus de 750 amendements à examiner
mais un débat plutôt courtois plutôt
feutrée compte tenu des évènements de la
semaine dernière tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle pour la séance sur le
président vous souhaitez vous demander
la parole monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
hier soir nous avons longuement débattu
de la politique de l'emploi
je voulais l'espace d'un instant revenir
sur ce sujet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur
au sénat je tiens à le souligner une
région qui n'a entre les mains que les
leviers que nous avons voulu lui donner
en ajoutant à ses pouvoirs la politique
économique n'avancerait que d'un pabx
boiteux si elle ne se voyait pas
reconnaître plus de pouvoirs en matière
de politique de l'emploi la commission
dans sa réflexion s'est voulu
extrêmement modéré c'était dans notre
esprit une avancée importante que de
reconnaître les pouvoirs du président du
conseil régional
mais nous n'avons pas voulu aller
jusqu'à mettre en cause les grandes
structures telles qu'elles ont été
organisées il ya quelques années avec la
création de pôle emploi nous sommes
arrêtés avant d'envisager de telles
efforts mais je voudrais souligner un
point important m'adressant directement
au gouvernement
nous avons ici une long débat avec le
premier ministre le 28 octobre moderne
ce débat a été parfaitement clair la
première avancée avant même qu'on le lui
demande qui a été faite par le premier
ministre dans sa volonté d'ouvrir le
dialogue avec le sénat apporté
expressément et ce sont ses termes même
sur la politique de l'emploi
c'est vous dire que la commission et je
pense beaucoup de nos collègues sont
très déçus de voir madame le ministre
les la prudence que nous jugeons
excessive dont vous avez fait preuve sur
ce dossier et nous allons pour notre
part continuer à réfléchir à
l'affirmation d'une compétence emploi du
président de la région qui permettent à
ce texte de devenir un véritable texte
de décentralisation les résultats de la
politique de l'emploi au cours des
dernières années
la flambée du chômage ne doivent pas
laisser supposer et postuler que
l'organisation actuelle est
satisfaisante
et dans ce domaine comme dans beaucoup
d'autres nous considérons nous qui avons
foi et confiance dans les libertés
locales que l'affirmation du rôle des
élus est sans doute une voie de solution
pour permettre à la politique de
l'emploi qui est inefficace
aujourd'hui de devenir plus efficace
merci madame la ministre
merci merci monsieur le président vous
savez monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
je pense que nous partageons le constat
je disais avant que la séance ne souffre
comme je disais hier soir d'où est
partie la demande d'ailleurs de
l'association régionale de l'association
des régions de france qui a fait cette
demande déjà il ya plusieurs mois
même avant la discussion de la loi sur
la formation professionnelle
les présidents de région et ceux qui
sont comme vous sur le terrain
constatant la difficulté nous ont tous
dit problèmes que nous avons majeur
c'est le nombre d'intervenants sur les
territoires ce n'est plus le chiffre de
ma région sans doute avez-vous le
chiffre sur la vôtre mais je le
retrouverai avant la fin de nos débats
énormément en intervenant dans des
structures qui parfois ont été
géographiquement rassembler et donc
fonctionnent ensemble ça a été un grand
pas mais pas c'est pas le cas partout et
une impossibilité pour le président de
la région et surtout l'ensemble de la
région pour ce convention d'ailleurs on
pourrait l'imaginer aussi c'est ce que
nous avions réfléchi à un moment la
possibilité de coordonner et madame la
rapporteure au nord de la commission
économique disait fort justement qu'en
plus de vence cette grande difficulté
devant la demande des citoyens
énormément de communes et des
intercommunalités ont elles mêmes créés
en plus des observatoires des agences
autres structures pour essayer de
réussir d'ailleurs ce qui est notre plus
grande question d'un confrère
confrontation entre l'offre et la
demande puisque l'on sait
on a près de 400000 emplois qui ne sont
pas pourvus d'où d'ailleurs ce que
j'avais proposée
avant la fin des états généraux de 2012
au sénat qui était de dire première des
actes à faire c'est de décentraliser au
maximum la formation professionnelle
pour pouvoir aller au delà
ce constat étant largement partagé j'ai
reçu bien évidemment vous imaginez
depuis bien avant même la demande
expresse 1 de votre commission vous le
savez puisque dès que ces questions se
sont posées dès la première discussion
de la loi matin j'ai reçu en présentant
des maires de france des départements de
france des régions de france bien sûr
mais aussi président des missions
locales
il ya une vraie crainte je vous le
disais est en fait il faut qu'elles
s'expriment parce que je pense que tant
qu'on met pas des mots sur les choses
n'avancent peut-être pas une vraie crâne
par exemple des missions locales d'une
tutelle de la région
le mot a été prononcé on m'a opposé
beaucoup le remplacement d'un
jacobinisme d'anciens et analyser de
diverses manières par à jacobinisme
régionales c'est ces termes cette
expression est monté dans pratiquement
toutes les délégations
nous ne voulons pas de jacobinisme
régionales je pense que nous avons donc
collectivement mal fait nous avons fait
fausse route et mon dernier point c'est
que pour la paix je suis parlementaire
j'étais parlementaire pardon avant
d'être gou vernement j'étais parlementer
un entendant l'opposition pour être très
juste
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur moi
c'est la première fois que j'entends et
je ne parle pas de moi naturellement
mais du premier ministre et du
gouvernement
la première fois que j'entends un
gouvernement dira à une famille
politique qui n'est pas dans sa majorité
vous avez raison il faut qu'on bouge et
on s'engage à prendre en compte votre
position à la faire cheminer dans la
navette parlementaire et a trouvé la
meilleure des réponses possibles à ce
que vous avez proposé
c'est la première fois je n'avais jamais
vécu une ouverture du site
donc j'espère quand même qu'on pourra
dit
ici que pour la première fois majorité
au sénat opposition au gouvernement a
été entendu par le premier ministre le
gouvernement qui s'engage qui s'engagent
et vous disiez nous sommes prêts à
travailler gouvernement est prêt à
travailler avec vous parce
qu'effectivement j'ai relu après la
séance comme sans doute beaucoup d'entre
vous malgré l'heure tardive certain
nombre de questions de droit qui se
posent par rapport à toutes nos
structures et à la coordination de la
région il y a beaucoup de choses à
régler avant qu'on puisse trouver la
bonne solution
donc il ya un engagement du premier
ministre qu'a était bien sûr dit le 28
octobre réitérer ici il ya une
opposition des missions locales et de
son association mais je vais les
rencontrer avec le ministre du travail
aussi vite que possible
il ya un vrai sujet sur les maisons de
l'emploi qui ici ou là et draine
effectivement beaucoup de financement
mais empêche peut-être de coordonner
d'autres structures donc il faut qu'on
ait entre aujourd'hui et non nous ne
voulons pas rien comprendre
nous voulons comprendre nous voulons
agir ce je pense que ce jugement la vie
ils ne veulent rien comprendre n'est pas
acceptable
monsieur le président non mais permettez
moi alors je veux bien être
conservatrices mais je peux vous dire je
peux vous dire monsieur le rapporteur de
la commission des lois que le discours
sur le jacobinisme régionales je n'en
suis pas l'initiatrice
il est beaucoup parti d'ici pour
beaucoup de matières et pour cette
matière là tout d'un coup on on le met
de côté moi je m'engage je vous disais à
l'instant monsieur président de la
commission des lois a rencontré le
président n'a mission des missions
locales a rencontré un certain nombre
d'acteurs et je vous le redis parce que
je trouve quand même qu'il n'ya pas de
donner acte non plus des pâquis son fait
et on n'y arrivera pas si on se donne
pas mutuellement acte des pas qui sont
faits je m'engage parce que le premier
ministre le veut
que entre hier soir difficulté et la
navette parlementaire nous trouvions une
solution
moi ça ne me choque pas que à titre
personnel que le président du conseil
régional soit président du com et de la
commission qui vient d'être créée le 1er
janvier
ça ne soit aucunement aucune non ça
choque certains maires de france sachant
que certains départements de france il
faut aussi que nous le sage sur le
conservatisme il n'est pas forcément du
côté où vous voulez qu'on le mette
canton quand on entend à mr dire je ne
veux pas que le président du conseil
régional s'occupe de ma mission locale
c'est pas le gouvernement
cette amère lorsque l'association des
maires de france nous dit attention au
jacobinisme régionales ce n'est pas le
gouvernement c'est l'association des
maires de france et toutes tendances
politiques confondues qui nous demande
d'être prudent sur le rôle à donner au
président du conseil régional
donc je ne veux pas qu'on puisse tout
d'un coup transformé le tout parce que
nous devons prendre en compte bien
évidemment ce qui a été fait par le
sénat ce que dit l'association des
maires de france association des
départements de france et l'association
des régions de france
ce que disait claudy lebreton et juste
pourquoi est ce que nous n'avons pas le
texte le meilleur qui soit parce que les
trois associations n'ont pas réussi
entre elles n'ont plus affaire
propositions et qu'elles ont passé plus
de temps à s'opposer aux propositions
qu'ils allaient construire je peux grand
mage la claudy lebreton parce que je
pense que effectivement nous avons vécu
ça et portant les textes de
décentralisation depuis deux ans et demi
je peux vous dire que les conservatismes
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois ne sont pas incarner que par
moi j'en ai rencontré beaucoup d'autres
donc je crois et et qui sont en plus des
gens de bonne foi n'est pas rencontrer
des gens qui sont conservateurs par
essence
ils sont de bonne foi donc nous devons
faire et fort le gouvernement s'engage
et si la commission veut continuer à
travailler ce sera avec un immense
plaisir qu'on continuera à travailler on
s'engage à travailler ce texte de la
commission des lois
voir à quel point on peut peut-être
trouvé d'accord mais quand même quand
même
un gouvernement qui s'engage devant une
famille qui n'est pas la sienne à dire
oui vous avez raison il faut qu'on
trouve une solution
je ne conclus mon propos là dessus c'est
la première fois depuis que je suis les
travaux parlement que j'entends un
gouvernement faire une telle ouverture
merci madame la ministre bien cette
discussion est close nous allons madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues en l'ordre du jour qui
appelle la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi portant nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république
alors vous le savez la discussion des
articles sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 847 tendant inséré un article
additionnel à part après l'article 11
bis d'ailleurs monsieur collombat qui
avait demandé la parole pourra le faire
je pense à ce moment parce que c'est un
moment je pense va relancer le débat
le 847 et qui est présentée par monsieur
favier oui monsieur le président madame
la ministre
avant d'évoquer cette cet amendement
devrait revenir simplement sur les
propos effectivement que madame la
ministre vient de tenir suite à
l'interpellation de notre président de
la commission des lois
on peut partager évidemment les propos
de notre président de la commission des
loi tendant à dire que cette loi puisse
aller au delà d'une loi de clarification
pouet éventuellement une véritablement
une loi de décentralisation
la proposition qui est faite par la
commission de transe de transférer donc
une part de responsabilité concernant la
politique de l'emploi aux régions est
évidemment un sujet sur lequel
évidemment on peut tout à fait
évidemment réfléchir pour autant à ce
stade je crois qu'il faut moi je partage
l'opinion de exprimées par la ministre
sur une certaine prudence sur un sujet
comme celui là pourquoi
d'abord parce que
il faut bien analyser pourquoi il ya ce
manque d'efficacité des structures
existantes les structures existantes ne
sont pas toutes que des structures
étatiques
certes il ya des difficultés de pôle
emploi et on dans les difficultés de
pôle emploi il ya notamment par exemple
les réorganisations incessantes les
dimunition moyens moins régulièrement
dans mon département je reçois des
délégations de personnel venant de pôle
emploi qui ne comprennent pas comment on
réorganise en permanence leur leur
travail en éloignant souvent d'ailleurs
les usagers de les demandeurs donc de
des services en réduisant parfois y
compris la capacité de répondre donc n
ya un vrai problème de moyens qui est
façon posée à pôle emploi
mais au-delà de ça il ya aussi de toute
une série de structures qui existent qui
travaillent sur l'emploi qui sont des
structures qui relève d'ailleurs des
collectivités et qui rencontrent les
mêmes difficultés
il faut faire le bilan des missions
locales je crois pas qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde soit forcément totalement
satisfait du bilan des missions locales
les maisons de l'emploi je trouve que là
encore c'est des structures qui sont
venues se rajouter à d'autres structures
mais dont on pourrait aussi faire
l'évaluation et ont je crois qu'on
pourrait avoir un regard assez critique
sur l'évaluation de ce qui a été mis en
place et en tout cas pour notre part
pour le groupe communiste
nous sommes absolument opposés à tout
désengagement de l'état en matière
d'action sur la politique de l'emploi
oria de ce point de vue je souhaite
évidemment avoir des garanties le nom
n'est pas évidemment opposé à ce que des
régions vont fasse plus
encore faudrait-il qu'elle précise avec
quels moyens elles vont pouvoir le faire
mais en tout état de cause il ya une
question d'égalité des citoyens sur le
territoire et on ne pourra pas accepter
pour notre part que les citoyens soient
moins bien traité dans telle ou telle
région en fonction évidemment des
capacités ou de l'engagement que telle
ou telle région mettrait à se préoccuper
de cette question
donc il ya un véritable problème
démocratique qui est posé un regard cela
t'as raison pour laquelle pour ma part
je serais plutôt partisans au stade où
nous en sommes d'avoir une réunion avec
l'ensemble des présidents de région
qu'on a un travail de concertation avec
eux pour savoir qu'est ce qu'il est
possible de faire pour améliorer un
dispositif qu'est ce que les régions
peuvent faire davantage parce que si on
cherche à tout prix effectivement avoir
un texte de décentralisation il y avait
éventuellement d'autres sujets avec
aurait pu être abordés on parle de la
politique de l'emploi
mais par exemple est ce que les
universités doivent être continué d'être
gérée par l'état où est ce que est ce
que des régions éventuellement ne
pourrait pas éventuellement les prendre
au même titre par exemple que les
régions s'occupent des lycées que les
départements s'occupe des collèges
plutôt que de transférer les collèges
aux régions est ce que c'est pas plutôt
vers l'université que doivent se tourner
les régions sachant le rôle extrêmement
important pour le développement
économique pour la recherche pour
l'innovation que joue évidemment et les
universités et l'importance je crois du
lien entre la région et l'université
ouais donc il ya d'autres sujets qui
pourraient permettre effectivement
d'aller vers un véritable une véritable
loi de décentralisation telle que nous
l'appelions de nos de nos voeux sur la
question de l'emploi donc je pense qu'il
faut malgré tout donc être prudent à ce
stade est que il faut en tout cas
entendre ce que disent les personnels
qui travaillent dans ce domaine là
entendre les personnels qui y
travaillent également dans les missions
locales pour trouver effectivement
travailler évidemment avancé pour
réduire le chômage dans notre dans notre
département et je pense qu'elles sont
bien les efforts supplémentaires qui
peuvent être faits mais voyez nord sur
l'amendement proprement dit excusez moi
monsieur le président la proposition que
nous faisons à travers cette a devancé
contenu d'un changement aussi important
que conduirait donc éventuellement donc
à confier aux régions une partie de la
politique de l'emploi
nous il nous semble nécessaire qu'un
changement est aussi important
nécessiterait donc une évaluation
régulière pour mesurer le degré
d'efficacité ou d'inefficacité
d'ailleurs de ce nouveau dispositif
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons qu'il ya un rapport puisse
être donc soumis régulièrement à un
rapport par le grand puis 7 rédiger
régulièrement donc chaque chaque année
sur l'évaluation donc de ce nouveau
dispositif merci monsieur feuillus
monsieur respect sur un porteur oui
d'abord le parlement doit évaluer les
politiques publiques
on va pas toujours demander des rapports
des rapports des rapports
donc comme une hostilité quand même
assez généralisé aux rapports annuels et
cetera qui sont en plus peu exploitée on
préfère que les évaluations donc c'est
un avis défavorable pas ce sont celui là
spécialement monsieur mais d'une manière
générale monsieur le président favier
défavorable merci monsieur rapporteur
madame la ministre pour l'avis du
gouvernement mais ma vie ne se plait
merci
y at il des explications de vote nous ce
que l'on bat bien et tu en as est
allergique au rapport qui sert pas à
grand chose
voterez pas cet amendement mais ça me
permet de revenir sur le fond notre
discussion que je trouve ces étonnantes
le problème n'est pas de savoir d'être
conservateur ou d'être réformiste moi je
suis conservateur s'il s'agit de
conserver ceux qui fonctionnent les
départements par exemple tiens est par
contre je suis réformateur parce que je
pense que le de nos problèmes majeurs
sinon le problème majeur de notre époque
c'est le chômage
quel bien sûr différentes dimensions du
lait pour d'une politique anti chômage
et à la politique macroéconomique
exemple je ne pense pas que se serrer la
ceinture ça soit le bon moyen de créer
des débouchés
parce que vous vouliez vous vouliez pas
on embauche et en investi que si on a
des perspectives de ventes
enfin je sais que je suis très
minoritaire je m'arrête ya aussi tout ce
qui peut être fait en matière de
l'amélioration du matériel pour
améliorer la compétitivité
et puis il ya aussi la mobilité du
personnel et c'est là qu'une politique
de l'emploi aussi peut intervenir et
depuis pas mal de temps je citais hier
le rapport boulot on s'est posé la
question quand on a essayé de répartir
du mieux répartir les compétences des
collectivités territoriales
2 la question de la politique de
l'emploi et il nous est paru à l'époque
que si lier la compétence action
économique et la compétence politique de
l'emploi au niveau de la région qui est
quand même une maille intéressantes
notamment si maintenant on a deux
grandes régions encore plus plus tôt
c'était peut-être pas une mauvaise idée
d'autant que si on observe ce qui peut
se passer dans différents pays
et bien sûr on s'aperçoit que les
résultats sont pas sont pas mauvais
parce que quand vous observez aussi ce
qui se passe sur le terrain
eh bien vous vous apercevez que il ya
effectivement dans les régions un manque
dans certaines professions
un excès dans d'autres etc et si la
formation professionnelle et du domaine
de la région ça n'a quand même rien
d'extraordinaire qu'on lui confie cette
branche donc de la politique de la
politique de l'emploi
c'est quand même tout à fait logique
alors je suis étonné que finalement
quand on parle de politique de l'emploi
alors je comprends pourquoi parce que la
commission a voulu aller doucement dans
cette dans cette affaire on ne parle que
finalement de de bureaucratie on ne
parle que de gestion des flux enfin et
c'est alors que le la problématique
c'est quand même comment améliorer la
formation et comment améliorer la
mobilité sur place dès des gens qui sont
en demande en demande d'emploi donc
encore une fois je dirais j'irai que je
ne comprends pas bien la position du
gouvernement
à moins que je ne la comprennent trop
c'est à dire que on est révolutionnaire
pour les autres mais dès qu'il s'agit de
bouger ce qui vous intéresse directement
j'aurai d'autres
j'aurai d'autres exemples on ne bouge
absolument pas quant à savoir élan quant
à savoir si ça serait créé des
inégalités entre les citoyens je n'en
crois rien le toute opération de
décentralisation
permet précisément des transferts de
compétence mais de manière encadrée avec
des obligations qui font que on évite
cet écueil de la diversité de la de
l'inégalité des situations on pourrait
en dire en même temps la même chose on
par exemple en matière d'urbanisme
l'urbanisme a été transférée c'est pas
pour ça qu'il ya eu des inégalités et
citoyens devant sète dans l'exercice de
cette compétence
donc je crois qu'on passe à côté alors
on annoncé qu'ils allaient se passer des
évolutions faim etc
je ne méconnais pas les problèmes que
cela pose
en fait je suis quand même encore une
fois très étonné de voir qu'on envisage
froidement de supprimer les départements
comme ce jeune pas sans se poser la
question de ce qui pourra se passer
après mais alors là dès qu'il s'agit de
savoir si on nomme deux ou trois
personnes de plus au conseil
d'administration de gestion et quelle
administration et cetera alors la levée
de boucliers faut pas bouger
oh mais vous vous rendez compte enfin
franchement encore une fois s'il ya
quelque chose à faire en matière de
décentralisation c'est bien ça c'est
bien dans le domaine de l'emploi la
politique de l'emploi lié politiques
économiques et politiques de l'emploi
si monsieur koulouba monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président je
voudrais dire à notre collègue favier
que j'interprète son amendement comme
une manière de donner acte au sénat du
vote qui l'a fait en adoptant l'article
3bis signifie que les dispositions qui
ajoute au pouvoir du président de région
en matière de l'emploi on les prend pour
acquise
et on veut les évaluer et en vérité je
crois que nous sommes tous d'accord sur
la nécessité lorsqu'il y à un changement
de cette importance de procéder à une
évaluation
nous avons simplement des réticences a
ajouté un nouveau rapport imposer au
gouvernement alors que
la commission nationale de la
négociation collective qui siège auprès
du ministre du travail va de toute façon
chaque année faire le bilan des
évolutions de la politique de l'emploi
le rendre public et le faire délibérer
par les partenaires sociaux qui sont
réunis autour du ministre du travail
mais je voudrais aussi insisté sur un
autre point
c'est vrai que au débat entre
conservateurs et réformistes se
superpose un débat entre jappo bas et
girondins et puisque madame la ministre
se poser elle même cette question du
jacobinisme régionales je voudrais lui
dire qu'il y avait effectivement un
jacobinisme régionales mais qu'il ya
aussi un gironde isme régional et je
vais vous expliquer la différence et
jacomin celui qui veut aspirer au niveau
régional des compétences déjà
décentralisée c'est à dire que est
l'auteur d'une nouvelle forme de
centralisme régional et en l'occurrence
super régionale puisque ce sont deux
grandes régions qui sont mis en place
celui qui veut siphonner les compétences
de collectivités de proximité pour les
faire s'exercer à un niveau plus
éloignées ça ça s'appelle jacobinisme
régionales ou centralisme super régional
le giron 10 mhz régionales c'est la
décentralisation de pouvoir exercer
jusqu'à lors par l'état voulait faire
s'exercer par des collectivités
régionales
c'est un schéma classique c'est celui
qu'on a observée dans toutes les lois de
décentralisation depuis 1980 d'eux mêmes
et même avant prendre à l'état des
compétences exercées par les bureaux des
ministères à paris pour les délégués à
des élus qui sont proches des forces
vives d'un territoire
ça s'appelle le giron 10me régionales où
la décentralisation et bien madame la
ministre
puisque vous voulez que nous échappions
à cette discussion entre conservateurs
et réformistes
moi je voulais quand même essayer de
vous
montrer que le sénat est à senna
réformateurs et de proximité et que le
gouvernement sur ce point là voulaient
aller moins loin que le sénat je crois
que ces deux objectifs sortons en effet
je l'acceptent de ce débat et admettons
que le débat il est bien sur ce point
entre les girondins qui veulent plus de
régions sur certains points et les
jacobins qui veulent moins de
départements sur d'autres
merci monsieur le président alors je
vais mettre voit cet amendement 1 847
qui était présentée par monsieur favier
qui et pour qui est content qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée à
l'article 4
j'ai une demande de parole de monsieur
michel bouvard la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre ce ministre mes chers collègues
en saluant tout d'abord l'esprit
d'ouverture exprimé par marylise
lebranchu
j'espère qu'on pourra être entendue sur
ce sur cet article qui concerne le
tourisme
je voudrais là aussi bon on peut être
dans l'opposition et reconnaître quand
les choses vont bien je crois qu'il faut
se féliciter du fait que laurent fabius
aient pris le dossier du tourisme à bras
le corps c'est sans doute là la
troisième fois après bernard pons et
michelle demessine qu'on a un ministre
qui s'intéressent au tourisme et qu'il
exprime durablement alors l'article
l'article évidemment a trait aux
compétences et ce que je voudrais
rappeler préalablement c'est que le
tourisme globalement marche bien donc il
faut s'efforcer de ne pas abîmer ce qui
fonctionne de manière satisfaisante
il faut aussi prendre en compte le fait
que nous avons en france des territoires
à intensité touristique différentes il
n'y a rien de comparable avec ce que
peut être le tourisme dans une région
comme la picardie pour qui j'ai la plus
grande estime et ce qu'il peut être dans
certaines parties de région plus vaste
le seul département du var et des
alpes-maritimes en provence avec la avec
la côte d'azur représente je dire la
première destination touristique de
france dans la région paca et s'agissant
des territoires de montagne les
départements savoyards représentent à
eux seuls 85% du tourisme de toute la
région rhône alpes je pense donc en la
matière même la ministre que nous avons
de grands défis devant nous celui de la
présence de l'état sur le territoire qui
gagnerait parfois être moins tatillonnes
geyer de transmit andré vallini un
dossier sur les procédures qui sont
actuellement suivis pour le
renouvellement des labels de communes
touristiques ou de station touristique
avec des lourdeurs invraisemblable et
des demandes de renseignements
invraisemblable lorsqu'il s'agit de
stations de 35 mille lits touristiques
comme les arcs où on s'interroge pour
savoir s'ils remplissent les critères
nous avons l'aide le défi de la
rénovation du mobilier de loisirs nous
avons la promotion internationale de la
france et puis nous aurons aussi le
disque le défi des moyens des
collectivités touristique car une
commune touristique
c'est pas seulement une rente c'est une
entreprise qui doit être un secteur
concurrentiel par rapport aux
destinations étrangères
alors je veux dire un mot du sujet sur
lesquels j'aurai un certain nombre
d'amendements c'est à dire le tourisme
en montagne le tourisme montagne c'est
250 stations ses 10 millions de
touristes en hiver c'est 120 mille
emplois
c'est cinquante mille 50 8 millions de
journées skieurs ces deux milliards
d'euros de résultat à la balance des
exportations et à la balance des
paiements de notre pays et c'est 300
millions d'investissements sur les
domaines ce qui a porté par les
collectivités dans certains territoires
et je reviens au territoire savoyard
s'est 61% des journées skieurs de toute
la france 85% du tourisme de rhône alpes
61% des journées skieurs de l'ensemble
du pays un million trois cent soixante
seize mille lits touristiques c'est à
dire plus
que la population des deux départements
un tiers de clientèle étrangère 48 mille
emplois salariés
bien évidemment dans ce contexte nous
souhaitons même la ministre mme sionisme
chers collègues que les collectivités
qui ont agi dans ce secteur puisse
continuer à le faire sans passer dans
une logique de tutelle sans être enfermé
dans des carcans sans voir les centres
de décisions s'éloigner et se voir
imposer des schémas qui ne
correspondront pas forcément aux
attentes des collectivités sur le
terrain je pense que nous devons garder
de la souplesse
il y a des marges de progrès il y à des
gains à faire en matière d'efficacité en
matière de dépenses dans la promotion
c'est un sujet qui a longuement été
évoquée déjà l'autre jour mais nous
avons surtout besoin de pouvoir
maintenir des capacités de décision sur
les stratégies d'investissement sur les
stratégies de développement qui
aujourd'hui appartiennent aux communes
station qui aujourd'hui appartiennent au
département exploitant le domaine
skiable pour beaucoup d'entre eux et
principaux partenaires des communes dans
le développement du tourisme en montagne
voilà le message que je souhaitais
portée et le sens des différents
amendements que j'aurai l'occasion de
défendre pour permettre que cette
autonomie et cette capacité de décision
ne soit pas entamée et que nous
puissions donc gardé une efficacité du
tourisme de montagne telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui et qui a permis de
faire de la france la première
destination mondiale avec des marques
qui ne sont pas ni rhône-alpes niveau
jdi massif central mais qui sont des
marques de stations pour beaucoup
d'entre elles qui sont connus dans le
monde entier et c'est aussi cela que
nous devons comprendre percée monsieur
louvard alors je suis saisie de trois
amendements identiques de suppression un
article cat un amendement 177 rectifié
qui est présentée par monsieur le
président mesdames
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je souhaite faire une mise
au point ce que j'ai entendu parler de
jacobinisme national régional
je rappelle que celui qui a dit vous
avez aimé le jacobinisme nationale vous
allez adorer le jacobinisme régionales
c'est un député socialiste
récemment bon et que moi j'en ai plus
qu'assez que l'on présente
systématiquement l'idée de jacobinisme
comme un monstre comme quelque chose qui
serait un gars et c'est parce que si
vous êtes là si nous sommes là c'est
parce que jacobinisme et il a fait la
france
c'est cet exode cet examen chers
collègues mais il n'en reste pas moins
qu'à des heures qu'à des heures
difficiles la république est elle vient
de là ça ne veut pas dire que c'est
parfait mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
sortir de ces schémas rapide
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi
voilà ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que il y a la volonté
d'assurer une unité de la nation et un
développement équilibré partout de la
nation avec tes droits et des devoirs
qui sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
alors cessons 1 ces caricatures
parce que je ne crois pas que ce soit
bon sur sur notre amendement
effectivement on nous demandons la
suppression cela parce que moi je ne
confonds pas le pouvoir régional à
l'excès pouvoir j'ai eu l'occasion de
montrer hier à nos ministres
un magnifique courrier d'un président de
région un qui a été une démonstration de
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire d'un
autoritarisme qui n'a d'ailleurs rien à
voir avec le jacobinisme mais qui
représente l'excès de pouvoir alors ce
qui est ce qui est gênant dans le texte
y compris celui de la commission ce
texte dit quoi la région élabore le
schéma régional de développement
touristique qui fixe les orientations
stratégiques d'aménagement de
développement précise les actions des
collectivités territoriales ou de leurs
groupements compétents en matière
fonction sas je suis désolé c'est le la
tutelle c'est de la tutelle bon le
schéma peut prévoir alors là c'est peu
la mutualisation la fusion le schéma
peut prévoir la mutualisation donc aussi
au niveau des régions
mais quand vous y mettez avec mes chers
collègues l'excellent amendement de
notre collègue patriat là-dessus qui lui
ne veut pas la suppression et l' inverse
que demande-t-il plus ils demandent la
compétence exclusive aux régions et ça
se termine comme en l'exposé des motifs
en étroite collaboration avec le niveau
communal et intercommunal ok le schéma
adopté par région et demandant la
compatibilité des interventions du bloc
communal sur le territoire régional
vesa ccsa qui veulent les présidents de
région il faut le dire il faut le dire
et ça c'est de la tutelle et ça c'est
inacceptable et c'est pour ça que tel
que c'est rédigé et bien on ne peut
aller que dans ils n'iront que dans ce
sens là où je suis pas contre
l'élaboration de certains schémas je
suis même très placide planificateur mai
mais pas de cette manière là si on
laisse faire ça c'est une erreur
profonde
merci monsieur brice dans les arts le
587 n'est pas défendu de 848 monsieur
favier oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mama ministre
lors de nos débats sur la loi map tam la
question de la compétence tourisme avait
été le l'occasion de nombreux échanges
et et de prises de position d'ailleurs
parfois opposées dans le texte de cette
loi initialement déposé par le
gouvernement
le département à l'époque devenait le
chef de file en matière de tourisme
les demandes alors de cette option
soutenait avec le gouvernement que ce
rapprochement permettait de mieux
structurer et coordonner la politique
touristique au plus près des acteurs de
ce secteur et des professionnels notre
commission avait proposé quand elle que
ce soit la région qui soit désigné chef
de file n'ont pas du tourisme mais du
développement touristique l'intégrant
donc au développement économique mais en
estimant que la notion de développement
touristique permettait de préserver donc
l'exercice de la compétence tourisme par
chaque échelon local en ce domaine
finalement cette compétence tourisme
c'est ne fut rattachée par notre sénat
puis par l'assemblée nationale a aucune
collectivité particulière laissant donc
celle ci comme étant donc une compétence
partagée aussi détonnant que moins d'un
an après la promulgation de cette loi il
ne soit demandé donc de revenir sur
notre position d'alors avec en plus un
gouvernement qui donc une nouvelle fois
changé d'avis en confiant maintenant le
chef de file à tourisme à la région
alors qu'auparavant ils soutenaient
nécessaire il avait soutenu l'idée que
ce soit plutôt le département qui veut
qu'on soit en soit en responsabilité en
fait cet article ce nouvel article
on voit bien ne se justifie que par la
volonté aujourd'hui gouvernementale
d'organiser le dépérissement des
départements en vue de leur disparition
programmée pour 2020 en renforçant
l'action des régions donc au détriment
des départements or il semble que des
déclarations qui ont été faites par le
premier ministre devant le congrès de
l'assemblée des départements de france
laisse entendre que cette disparition et
département n'est plus réellement
d'actualité
alors pourquoi donc désigné par cet
article la région lors du chef de file
sur le tourisme
nous considérons donc pour notre part
qu'il n'y a pas lieu de modifier le
dispositif actuel ce que nous avions
voté dans la webcam et c'est la région
de l'aigle pour laquelle ces régions de
notre amendement donc de suppression de
cet article 4 favier monsieur le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le président la commission
a profondément modifié l'article iv se
vendent une compétence exclusive ou ou
majoritairement régional nous avons fait
une compétence partagée
pas de chef de file mais quand même une
coordination par la région j'ajoute
monsieur président mézard que vous
verrez que notre article le neutre
amendement 1084 c'est vraiment une co
élaboration
aujourd'hui il ya les schémas régionaux
des schémas départementaux et nous on
veut plutôt ne pas multiplier schéma 1
donc en fait nan mais qui est quand même
besoin forcément une coordination entre
les collectivités c'est quand même pas
forcément mais ça ne reste que ça est en
fait la responsabilité des départements
dans le tourisme on sait très bien son
puissant et puis comme on l'a dit ça
peut aller jusqu'à au ville ou aux
interpro parfois mais quand vous avez
une station classée quelques fois c'est
fait soit promotion et fait très bien
tout seul pourquoi voulez-vous qu'on
aille dacquois fait qu'on aille donner à
d'autres c'est qui est bien fait
c'est le principe de subsidiarité
intelligemment appliquée et là
franchement je ne suis pas sûr que ça
soit le domaine où il ya des dérives
avec des dépenses de fonctionnement
excessive parce qu'en fait
économiquement le tourisme est quand
même très important dans notre pays et
donc on a cherché
c'est comme quand on verra on veut créer
obligatoirement des offices de tourisme
partout dans les intercoms c'est une
subtilité il ya des endroits où il en
faut il ya des endroits où on n'a pas
besoin
non mais franchement c'est donc
nous ne sommes pas favorables à la
suppression de l'article
mais on l'a quand même transformé
évidemment on va me dire fais pas ci
sera défendue à l'amendement de notre
excellent collègue patriat évidemment si
on veut si on veut faire ça c'est sûr
que ça ne peut que heurter tous ceux qui
depuis toujours se consacre au tourisme
avec efficacité
franchement je te vouloir des pouvoirs
ça n'a pas de sens
ça n'a pas de sens ça a un sens pour
certains ce qui est important c'est
comment exercer les responsabilités
publiques dans les divers domaines au
bon échelon et d'une manière pertinente
et je crois qu'en matière tourisme notre
système est quand même plutôt il peut
être mieux coordonnées mais ça doit
s'arrêter là et d'essai les compétences
bien exercée par un certain nombre
d'échelons telles qu'elles sont donc
nous ne sommes pas favorables à la
suppression de l'amendement à la
suppression de l'article
mais on l'a trouvé réconfort transformé
pour en faire quelque chose qui soit
utile mais pas excessif
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre
la vie n'est pas tout à fait la même
motivation mais nous ne sommes pas
favorable à l'amendement gouvernement
reprendra la parole n'est pas favorable
aux amendements devenir globale mais
reprendra la parole sur son propre
amendement on voir comment effectivement
on peut améliorer les choses
je voulais juste dire que l'une des
préoccupations du gouvernement et porte
sur le contenu de la compétence tourisme
parce qu'il ya effectivement tu être
plus à l'aise ici jeu j'éviterai
elles ont développement tout à l'heure
il ya effectivement des actions qui sont
très bien mené en terme d'accueil des
touristes
je pense que la proximité l'accueil mais
nous avons un problème majeur en france
puisque nous avons 80 3 millions de
visiteurs pour 50 millions de chiffre
d'affaires
quand par exemple l'espagne à 50
millions de visiteurs pour 83 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
milliards pardon je ne suis pas dans
millions sur milliards donc il ya un
vrai sujet effectivement de il ya
beaucoup d'intervenants je pense que sur
l'accueil des touristes
il n'y a pas lieu de modifier beaucoup
les choses mais il ya un vrai sujet de
construction de produits touristiques
qui est un accent fait de développement
économique majeure et sans doute que on
doit réfléchir au fait qu'on a une telle
différence par exemple entre la france
et l'espagne en termes de capacité
d'accueil des produits cours de produits
divers des produits de week-end de
tourisme urbain on a vraiment beaucoup
de questions à se poser donc le le
gouvernement et je vais du coup monsieur
le président de la séance
défendre une position on y reviendra
tout à l'heure on verra ce qu'on fera de
notre amendement penser que la
simplicité dans sur ce sujet la
simplicité c'était un chef de file 1
c'est un chef de file à ça veut dire que
l'ensemble des actions sont coordonnées
et le moins possible le moins possible
de normes
ensuite pour l'exercice de la compétence
je pense que si nous avions pu revenir à
un chef de file à je me pose même la
question je vous le dis est il
nécessaire d'avoir un schéma à la mesure
où sur les capacités d'accueil par
exemple la création de produits le lien
et des professionnels le schéma régional
de développement économique devrait à
mon sens comprendre les grandes
l'infrastructure actions touristiques
qui pourrait être conduite donc voyez on
se posait des questions chef de file à
permettrait de régler tous les problèmes
et peut-être de s'arrêter là sur le fait
qu' effectivement un schéma de plus je
ne suis pas certaine que le temps cadres
parce qu'il faut qu'on réfléchisse aussi
autant cadre consacrer si on a une
collab co-élaboration les régions les
départements les acteurs qualité et
communes ça veut dire beaucoup de
travail en commun beaucoup de lectures
de propositions de correction de la
proposition de retour c'est extrêmement
compliqué de co élaborés schéma avec
autant d'acteurs en tant que cadre et je
ne suis pas certaine que nous arrivions
résultats que nous souhaitons
communément ans combien pardon donc
voila moi je par rapport à l'ensemble
des des amendements je plaide plutôt
pour un chef du file 1 et puis que
chacun ensuite exerce ses compétences sa
compétence non merci madame la ministre
alors pour explication de vote monsieur
dantec oui monsieur le président j'adore
quand on a droit à un moment le rappel
historique de remise en perspective des
des choses je voulais rappeler au
président mézard que si les girondins
n'avaient pas participé à la révolution
c'est pas si elle aurait réussi que
quand on a commencé à couper la tête des
girondins voir à la fin de ce qu'ils
voulaient l'accord entre les girondins
et les ja commun comme dans ton
s'annonçait plutôt la fin de la
révolution donc toute perspective
historique et toujours à manier avec
précaution je peux d'autant plus parler
des jacobins que je rappelle aussi ce
qui est peu connu c'est le premier long
du club des jacobins c'est le club
breton et que donc on est
particulièrement bien placé pour parler
des des jacobins mais nous avons nous
avons beaucoup de beaucoup de paradoxes
ici est donc dans ces paradoxes après ce
léger rappel historique
il y a que j'ai eu un peu la tentation
rare de voter l'amendement du président
mézard ce que je ne serrerai riz bah oui
parce que je ne suis pas loin de
partager une partie de l'analyse sur le
fait que sur les la question de de
tourisme il faut tenir compte de la
diversité des des territoires il y a il
y à des régions qui sont une marque la
bretagne par exemple même si la bretagne
est un peu réduite et que la marque ne
correspond pas au territoire
administratif on a une chance un peu
historique de rattraper les choses et on
la rate et collectivement j'y reviens
pas c'est assez douloureux
un maître dans d'autres territoires
évidemment ça ne correspond à rien et
que là si la loi va trop loin on va
créer évidemment un sac d'embrouillés
absolument inextricable et on ne gagnera
absolument pas en efficacité de de
l'action publique
je crois notamment et donc le président
mézard verra encore un paradoxe je croit
notamment que le département joue un
rôle assez important dans le tourisme
notamment depuis que nous avons décidé
de la création des grandes régions
je croit notamment que nous allons aller
dans un certain nombre d'endroits alors
je sais pas si encore en alsacien dans
la salle mais pour la savoie en tout cas
ça joue aussi la question de la fusion
des départements et sur la table avec
des départements qui vont mieux
correspondre à d'anciennes identité
culturelle et pour aller au bout du quai
du paradoxe le département qui est quand
même plutôt l'invention jacques